ذلك اعلن الجيش الاوكراني صدى هاجمات
روسيه على مناطق متفرقه في شرق البلاد من
بينها ضخمه في حين قالت سلطاه ماري بولا
المواليه لروسيا ان دفاعتها الجويه صدت
هجوم بالطائره المسيره على المدينه من
جهتها اعلنت سلطات الانفصاليه المواليه
لروسيا ان القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت بشكل
مكثف المناطق الخاضعه لسيطرتها منذ امس
وحتى صباح اليوم ما اسفر عن اصابه مدنيين
وقال الانفصاليين اذا قصف استهدف بنى
تحتيه في مدينه
بسته صواريخ هايبرس الامريكيه واكد ايضا
ان دفاعات الجويه الروسيه تصدت ليله
الماضيه لصواريخ اوكرانيا فوق مدن دوناسك
وكم يفكا
معنى الان من كراماتورسك مراسل الجزيره
عامر لافي ومن دونيس الجزيره امين
درغامي ابدا معك عمر لافي عن التطورات
الميدانيه لا سيما بخموت وايضا جبهه
الشرقيه
نعم ازدهار يعني رسميا ربما ما زالت قياده
الاركان الاوكرانيه تتحدث في العموم تحدثت
عن صدها اوصد القوات الاوكرانيه لسبع
محاولات تقدم على طول خطوط المواجهه في
اقليم دومباس احدى هذه المحاور هي مخمود
وتحدثت عن قصف حوالي 21 قريه في محيط
مخمود قصفر روسيا شديدا بمختلف انواع
الاسلحه لكن بالحديث وبالتواصل مع مصادرنا
في محمود اللافت اليوم هو تاكيدهم لنا
بانه منذ ثلاثه ايام لم تحرز القوات
الروسيه اي تقدم يذكر على حد وصفهم وانا
انقل هنا عن هذه المصادر هذا الايام في
طبعا بالنسبه كما يقولون ان المعارك تضاعف
حجمها تعزيزات مستمره تكثيف في هذه
المعارك على المحاور الثلاثه التي يهاجم
منها الجيش الروسي هذه المدينه مدينه
محمود نتحدث طبعا ازدهار كما تعلمين ان
القتال يدور في المحور الشمالي والشرقي
والجنوبي للمدينه
تحاول قوات الروسيه وخصوصا طبعا من اشياء
فاجنر التي تقود العمليات هناك الى تطويق
هذه المدينه مما سيضطر القوات الاوكرانيه
الى الانسحاب منها اللافت ايضا اليوم هو
الخبر الذي تحدث عن استهداف عنيف لمدينه
شاسوفار وقطع امدادات الغاز عنها هذه
المنطقه تتعرض بشكل شبه يومي امدادات
الغاز والبنيه التحتيه للغاز استهدفت في
اكثر من مره لكن اليوم كان استهدافا على
ما يبدو مركزه وبالتالي قطعت امتدادات
الغاز عن كل هذه المدينه لماذا هذه
المدينه مهمه تعلمين ربما ان القوات
الروسيه سيطرت على الطريق الرئيسي او قطعت
تمكنت من قطع الطريق الرئيسي الواصل بين
سلافيانس ومخمول وتحاول قطع الطريق
الرئيسي الاخر بين قسطنطنيفكا وبخموت وهي
قريبه اصلا منه وبالتالي اصلا هذا الطريق
يصعب باستخدامه بسبب حده المعارك بالقرب
منه الان الطريق الاساسي الذي يعتمد لنقل
الافراد والمعدات ونقل الجرحى هو هي الطرق
الفرعيه التي تمر من هذه المدينه مدينه
شاص وفيار والذي تقول القوات الروسيه
بانها نقلت تقول قوات روسيه نقلت قيادتها
من مخمود الى هذه المدينه لتدير وتشرف على
المعارك في مدينه مخمود ربما ايضا الخبر
الاخر والمهم اليوم على المحور الشرقي على
الجبهه الشرقيه في اقليم دومباس ليس
اليوم حاكم لوغانس الاوكراني تحدث عن صد
محاوله تقدم روسيه عند محور كريمينا
القوات الروسيه تقدمت بسريه دبابات وسريه
مشاه ووحده مشاه نحو مواقع الجيش
الاوكراني الذي اوقعها في كمين وادى الى
تدمير العديد من الاليات دبابه وعده اليات
واستخدم حاكم لوغانس قال بانه تم تدمير
الوحده العسكريه او الفرقه العسكريه التي
حاولت التقدم من هذا المحور ربما اوضح
نقطه اخيره بخصوص هذا المحور وانه حصل
تغير الدراماتيكي منذ بدايه العام كان منذ
عده كانت القوات الروسيه هي التي تدافع
على هذا المحور على العكس من جميع مناطق
القتال في اقليم دومباس لكن مع بدايه هذا
العام حصل تعزيزات القوات الروسيه واصبحت
هي التي تهاجم على محورغاز
روسيا تقول او القوات الروسيه تقول بانها
تقدمت في محور باخبوت
ولكن ما حدود هذا التقدم ام ان الحديث عن
التقدم ربما نسبي
مع حده هذه المعارك عبد الصمد يبدو ان
التحرك والتقدم بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه
احيانا يقاس بلربه مع عشرات الامطار او
مئات الامطار بدل الكيلومترات باعتبار ان
هناك وذلك طبعا باعتراف روسي مقاومه عنيفه
من قبل الجيش الاوكراني ووجود تحصينات بدا
الان الحديث عنها بشكل واسع في لدى الجانب
الروسي في مدينه باخموت خاصه في الجزء
الصناعي من المدينه لربما هناك من يشبه
الان تلك المنطقه
بمنطقه ازوف ستال في مدينه ماريوبل وطبعا
ممكن ان تطول المعارك اذا ما اختار الجيش
الاوكراني مواصله القتال في هذه المدينه
بحسب المعطيات باعتبار انها يعني منطقه
مليئه بالانفاق هناك مصانع وايضا بعض
الطرق الوعره والمرتفعات المنخفضات الان
الحديث يجري عن هجوم من محورين من محور
شمالي غربي بعد ان كانت القوات الروسيه
تحديد القوات فاجنر قد سيطرت على محطه
قطارات تبكي تقدمت الى بلده بيرخوفكا الان
تحاول السيطره على هذه البلده التي سيطرت
عليها فانها باتت عند الضواحي الشماليه
الغربيه وباتت قبقوسين لنقل من الاقتحام
المدينه من تلك المنطقه وهناك ايضا هجوم
متزامن
لفاجنر من ناحيه الجنوب في محاوله للسيطره
الكامله على الطريق الرابط بين بخموت
وكانوفكا والتوجه الى الطريقه الاخير الذي
ما زال من خلاله يتلقى الجيش الاوكراني
المساعدات ودعم العسكري وهو الطريق الرابط
بين باخد
وتشيسوفيار لكن وسط هذه المعارك المحتدمه
والتي يبدو ان يعني يبدو انها لن تنتهي
بشكل سريع لربما كما كان يظن البعض هناك
تطورات ايضا ميدانيه لا تقل اهميه عبد
الصمد جرت الليله الماضيه والتماثلت في
حديث السلطات المواليه لروسيا عن استهداف
الجيش الاوكراني بصواريخ من طراز هايمرس
مدنا وقرى خاضعه لسيطرتهم بعيده هذه المره
عن خط اتماس الحديث عن مدن كاديبال
سواريز القريبه من الحدود الروسيه الحديث
ايضا عن
مهاجمه مدينه ماريوبول بيم طائرات مسيره
وقبل قليل فقط وزاره الاعلام هنا في دنيا
الموالي طبعا لروسيا قالت ان ان لديها
معلومات استخباراتيه تؤكد ان الجيش
الاوكراني حصل على صواريخ من طراز هايمر
قبل اسبوعين مداها يصل الى 150 كيلومترا
وليس 80 كيلومترا كما كان في وقت سبق
والان هذه الصواريخ بحسب سلطات المواليه
لروسيا لدى الجانب الاوكراني هي في طور
التجربه وربما هنا يجري الحديث عن على ما
يبدو انتقال من مرحله الى مرحله على
الايام القليله المقبله ستجيب عن ما اذا
كانت هذه انتقاله ام لربما مواصله على نفس
النجم من قبل شكرا لك امين امين
في من كراماتوس